california getting a sequel to a total
recall vote
18 years after the original democratic
governor gavin newsom facing a recall
election in the golden state
constituents of all political stripes
fed up with his extensive government
mandated lockdowns
and hypocrisy remember when he got
caught maskless at that fancy french
laundry restaurant
that was uh expensive dinner and that
news comes as california will lose a
house seat for the first time in history
thanks to the results of the 2020 census
greg where is this go well gavin
is legitimately terrified i have
received two emails from him
to gary gutfeld he's got my name wrong
but the message line the top
line for his fundraising email is please
give me a chance to
explain then he goes on to ask for money
do you know how much money he asked for
three dollars i don't know there's
something pathetic about asking for
three dollars
i guess it's the small donations but i
mean it's like i i don't know what's
that gonna do
look i i one thing i learned
from this fundraising email he says at
the end
turning the state over if the recall
wins
it will turn the state over to anti-mask
anti-vaxx pro-trump extremists
so if you ever want to learn how
liberals in the media will get their
information
look no further than a democrat
fundraising email because that just
sounds really familiar to you right now
dana i think it's pro-jobs small
business owners and parents who give a
damn about their kids who are angry
i think that that's obviously true but
it's not only those who have signed the
petition they're the ones that left
california
because not even the sunshine dollars
that they pay you with are going to make
a difference when you figure out a way
that you just don't want to live that
way anymore so people are getting those
one-way u-hauls and getting the heck out
of dodge dagon
one
well i just think that you know when you
look at the numbers uh his approval
rating is way north of 50 i think it's
at 54 percent right now degan
uh opposition to the recall is pretty
strong it's even stronger i think at 56
so my bet if i was betting right now is
that gavin newsom will be governor after
a recall i think you have to get like 12
of the previous people who voted in the
previous election to come out you can do
that
but it's hard to defeat somebody who's
that popular at this moment with regard
to the census numbers
people thought california was going to
lose more so the democrats are breathing
a big sigh of relief right now they
thought it was going to they were going
to lose more in florida and
it just didn't happen yeah because uh
jesse it's about
the seats in congress it's not actually
about the people you govern
and your state who are suffering
mightily from the mistakes the
anti-science mistakes made by newsome at
all in the last year so i just want to
meet gary gutfeld
guy sounds like a real buffoon but i'd
take my chances with him
maybe he'd be available on waters world
this weekend let's i need to look into
that maybe i could get his email
address what do i know degan i thought
gavin newsom was going to be the
democrat nominee for president
in 2024 now he's facing a recall in
caitlyn jenner's running and now randy
quade just
announced he's getting into the race he
just crossed the wires because you know
me i have my eyes on the water
it's about to be a circus out there in
california but i just think that state
is long gone there's no there's no
coming back
i thought randy quaid was still in
canada that's a fox news alert he's in
kelly
thank you jesse